WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG SATURDAY
SHOW DESPICABLE RAY'S HEATING
UP.
BACKYARD BEACH GAME YOU PLAY
WITH YOUR FRIENDS OR SOMEBODY
DOES, IT'S NOW GETTING BIG TIME
SPONSORSHIPS.
TOM BRADY IN THE BRAIN GAMES
PURCHASE DESPICABLE TEAMS COULD
PROPEL IT TO MORE POPULARITY.
THE SEVEN-TIME NFC CHAMP SHARING
EXCITEMENT FOR HIS NEW TEAM.
>> I'VE BEEN TRYING TO FIND A
WAY FOR A PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
CAREER NOW IN MY 40s, THE
BALL.
I'M EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE
UNOFFICIALLY JOINING THE NLP
FAMILY BUT I'M GOING TO WIN.
I'M COMING TO DOMINATE THE
SPORT.
PICKLE BALL.
LET'S -- GO.
>> FOR EVERYBODY WHO DOESN'T
KNOW, I DID RESEARCH, IT'S A
FAKE SPORT THAT INVOLVES IT WILL
FOOTBALL PING-PONG PADDLE AND
YOU TAKE OVER A TENNIS COURT,
PERFECTLY GOOD TENNIS COURT AND
NOBODY WATCHES.
SO, THE WAY I LOOK AT THIS, IS
IT A PLOT TO TAKE OVER THE
WORLD?
>> FOR PEOPLE WHO LOVE TENNIS
IT'S TERRIBLE.
PICKLE BALL IS A NO NO IN OUR
HOUSEHOLD.
MY HUSBAND AND I ARE TENNIS
PLAYERS, WE DID FOUR HOURS OF
TENNIS AND COERCED TO PLAY FIVE
MINUTES APPLICABLE WITHIN FIVE
MINUTES HE BLEW OUT HIS ANKLE.
LET'S NOT MAKE AMERICANS FATTER,
OKAY?
I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO PLAY TENNIS, RUN AROUND THE
WHOLE COURT AND LIKE TOM BRADY
SAID, THE ONLY PEOPLE SHOULD
PLAY THE COUPLE ARE CHRONIC
INJURIES AND PEOPLE OVER 55.
IF YOU'RE UNDER 55 WITHOUT
INJURIES, PLAY TENNIS.
>> WE HAVE VIDEO OF JORDAN
PLAYING PICKLE BALL, DO WE HAVE
THAT?
YOU GOT MEGASTARS PLAYING, DOES
IT MAKE YOU WANT TO PLAY?
>> I HAD TO GET UP AND SAY THIS
IS THE ONE WITH THE RACKET,
RIGHT?
I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE TO DEFEND.
>> LESS THAN HALF THE SIZE OF
THE COURT, YOU DON'T MOVE.
>> YOU DON'T GET EXERCISE DOING
THAT.
IF YOU CO-OPT PRO WRESTLING AND
MADE IT PART OF PICKLE, I'D
WATCH.
>> THAT WOULD BE GOOD.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WOULD
WORK.
FIRST OF ALL, YOU HATE GOING
HOME, I UNDERSTAND IT'S ROUGH.
[LAUGHTER]
SO I GET IT, I'D INVEST IN
STUFF, TO THE WE'VE SEEN THIS
WITH CORN HOLE ANYTHING THAT
GETS PEOPLE OUTSIDE AND WITH IT,
I WANT TO KNOW HOW MUCH THE
FRANCHISES ARE, THEY ARE
EXPENSIVE, MAYBE BRING THE
JERSEY SHORE AND PICKLE BALL,
GET SOME PERSONALITIES OUT
THERE.
YOU CAN DO DARTS IN ENGLAND AND
STUFF WITH THE WHOLE THING,
CAUTIONS AND ADDRESSING AT THE
ENTRANCE AND EVERYONE CUTS
PROMOS WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO DO
WHEN PICKLE BALL WHO COMES FOR
YOU AND ALL THAT IN THE GAME
STARTS AND EVERYONE GET
SOMETHING TO EAT.
IT'S FACT TENNIS, THAT'S WHAT IT
IS BUT IF IT GETS YOU OFF THE
COUCH AND YOUR PHONE, I'M FOR
IT.
EVEN IF YOU ARE MOVING A CHA-CHA
HIT AND WAIT FOR THE OTHER GUY
AND THE OTHER GUY, THAT'S BETTER
THAN SITTING ON THE COUCH EATING
CHINOS WATCHING 24 HOURS OF
REALITY TV SHOW.
>> I THINK THEY OUGHT TO BRING
BACK HOPSCOTCH.
AS A GOOD GAME.
>> THERE'S ANOTHER GAME CALLED
BADMINTON AND VOLLEYBALL.
>> WHAT ABOUT TETHERBALL?
>> I WAS TALLER THAN EVERYBODY
ELSE AND I WOULD NAPOLEON
DYNAMI